president Trump reacting to the news at
his rally in Wisconsin last night my
highest duty as you know as president is
to keep America safe democracy we all to
come together in peace and harmony the
media also has a responsibility to set a
civil tongue and to stop the endless
hostility and constant negative and
oftentimes false attacks and stories I
will take an around the table Pam could
we start with you I'm just trace
Gallagher saying that we can confirm now
that they're honing in on Florida as a
possible place where these packages were
sent from what can you tell us well
without details specifically to Florida
as a career prosecutor I've seen so many
of these cases with suspicious packages
and there is a wealth of information
Dana in these packages you wouldn't
believe I mean even that the duct tape
I've had a murder case we got a print
off a duct tape stamps that you used to
lick now we have touch DNA so if they
even touched the stamp we could get DNA
off the stamp as to the post office we
can even get the origin as to where it
came and I think they're working on all
that you know was it well planned yes
and no yes and that they all went out
simultaneously however no in that I mean
names were spelled wrong some of the
addresses we know were wrong and got
returned to sender you think they have
been on purpose though maybe but I know
that they know a lot more than we know
and that's how it should be right now
and I really have no doubt that they
will catch this person and very fast
I saw the president yesterday at the
White House and he was so somber you saw
you saw him at the way he was so somber
and very seriously everyone's taking
this and FBI's all over it Greg won't go
to you then and the ongoing conversation
you it's not any of the activity this
morning down there yeah well I was I
don't know what time it was but he had
the I'm a few blocks from there so I
woke up to the helicopters that were I
guess above me for at least a few hours
and I knew and I got up but I told my
wife I go something's happening there
it's definitely downtown and you know
and it was it then it went on for like a
couple of hours and found that it was
that that I guess his restaurant what
did you think of the conversation today
that was inevitable about President
Trump has toned him saying that the
media needs to watch its tone well it is
it's with all these things you're gonna
get finger pointing and I think the
thing is everybody can point their
fingers depending on what what group you
belong to and so it's natural it's hard
for me to take advice from the media
over heated rhetoric because if you were
to subtract the heated rhetoric of Trump
let's say the caustic behavior the jokes
about sleepy eyes and and lock them up
if you took that all away right said
like Trump didn't even exist you would
still have speakers on campus being
harassed you'd still have anti Fah
chasing down people on streets you'd
have still have politicians inciting
face to face harassment you'd have Kathy
Griffin Johnny Depp Madonna they did all
their stuff early on before a lot of
this stuff you have Mika obsessing over
the twenty-fifth amendment so it's all
and and you have weird at times people
defending Anti Fog so essentially you've
got two years of questioning Trump's
sanity calling him Hitler and you're
upset because he made a joke about a
body slam it doesn't work for me it does
I would think that the left feels
differently want I don't know if you've
heard from anyone today yeah I think the
left feels like you know it's it's sort
of difficult moment for all of us it's a
very divided country right now and I
think it's kind of sad that we have
reached this point but I think people on
the left are kind of taken aback that
the president last night seemed to be
more presidential and saying you know
what we need to unify we need to come
together you can't attack political
opponents and then this morning he
shifts again as you were suggesting to
Greg and says hey you know the
mainstream media needs to clean up its
act in terms of setting the tone the
response has been pretty clear from Jeff
Zucker at CNN the head of CNN and others
saying that the tone is really set by
the politician by the president this is
a president who has talked about you
know Second Amendment people taking care
of Hillary and body slamming reporters
the press is the enemy I can go on I
mean everybody knows this litany even
down to Charlottesville with fine people
on both sides so I think that there's a
sense that rarely you know his instant
is to be a combative president and that
in fact as the political strategy
approaching the midterms he sees the
division as firing up his base and I
think a lot of people are just worried
that you can't keep we can't as an
American people keep going down this
path without respecting I mean even you
know daresay loving each other as fellow
Americans last week in the NBC Wall
Street Journal poll ninety percent of
Americans said that we are the most
advisors that we've ever been so we
actually agree on something at least I
guess but we the conversation that we
could have about rhetoric could have
happened without these suspicious
packages that's true it's been boiling
up for a long time and just talking
about tone as Juan brought up look at
our table and we make fun of crooked
Hillary and we say Pocahontas oh we make
fun of spartacus and we Nexus you and we
you know we go after people's policies
and we mock them if they're being
deceitful and what-have-you but I don't
think anybody at this table says you
know this person is a Nazi this person
hates other ethnic groups I want to see
this political opponent I want to see
harm done to that person and I think
we're pretty responsible at that table
remember when Steve Scalise was shot by
a Bernie bro no one at this table blamed
Bernie Sanders and berfomet out with
Rachel Maddow and Bernie Sanders himself
never accepted responsibility Pelosi
never accepted responsibility when
people raise questions about democratic
record and Greg laid it out perfectly I
mean you the list is long people's ribs
have been cracked people have tried to
be stabbed cars have been fire bombed
anthrax and ricin has been sent around
and you look at people like Kathy
Griffin or Snoop Dogg or Hillary Clinton
the other day saying you know we don't
have to be civil sometimes we have to be
uncivil we don't ever make Democrats
accessories to the crimes politically
what the left is doing now is they're
trying to make Donald Trump an accessory
to these attempted mail bombings and
saying you're an accessory and therefore
you need to stop attacking the media and
you just stop attacking Democrats before
the midterm elections and I don't think
he has a responsibility to do that
I agree Trump talks tough sometimes
sometimes it's too tough a lot of the
times he's being tongue-in-cheek and the
media has no sense of humor and they
don't get that but I agree sometimes he
does cross the line but when you're
slamming someone in a video or you know
you're going like this and you're
mocking someone get punched at a protest
it's a little different then when the
media calls you a mentally ill Nazi that
needs to be taken out or fetishizes your
son being raped
I agree everybody needs to come together
but both sides need to look in the
mirror especially the media